n'est-ce pas un peu étrange qu'Elvis
Presley soit mort l'année de ton premier album
mon nom est truecamer
pas vraiment non je veux dire Groucho Marx est mort
la même année mais je ne m'appelle pas Groucho
costellos je veux dire il n'y a pas c'est juste une
coïncidence
alors pourquoi  tu travailles avec Chrissy Hind
et Paul McCartney sur ton nouvel album
Spike
[Music]
euh bien tout d'abord on m'a
demandé d'écrire des chansons avec Paul McCartney
et pendant que je travaillais avec lui sur l'
écriture j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique pour dire
que l'un des  les bassistes que je
voulais utiliser sur le disque ne seraient pas
disponibles,
alors M. McCartney a dit que
je le ferais comme une blague,
alors je l'ai retenu
Chrissy gêne, j'ai déjà chanté avec
elle dans une émission de charité
pour euh pour
quelques chansons et j'aime le son
de nos voix alors
j'ai commencé à chanter sur la chanson que je
pensais être vraiment bonne tu as dit
que quand tu avais neuf ans les
Beatles ont changé ta vie
quelle chanson Please Please
Me c'était le premier single  J'ai jamais possédé
et quand tu étais  15
votre vie a été complètement changée par
tamla Motel quelle chanson
Bernadette si vous n'aviez qu'une phrase
pour décrire Spike ce serait
totalement génial
votre nouvel album spike est sous-titré le
Beloved Entertainer d'après Elvis l'
Imposteur
Howard lâche le dentifrice émotionnel
Napoléon Dynamite et le royal  garde
tu sembles préférer l'Alias
non je ne le change pas mais seulement quand il
semble s'illuminer
je vois juste que mon nom est une grosse ampoule
que j'éclaire sur les chansons il y a 12 ans
quand ton manager Jake Riviera a proposé
que tu sois  appelé Elvis dans le nouveau-né
Cafe Westbourne Grove Londres w11 que
pensiez-vous que je pensais qu'il
était fou et je pensais qu'ils allaient
l'emmener à tout moment
n'est-ce pas un peu étrange qu'Elvis
Presley soit mort l'année de votre premier  album
je m'appelle truecamer
pas vraiment non je veux dire Groucho Marx est mort
la même année mais je ne m'appelle pas Groucho
costellos je veux dire y'a pas c'est juste un
hasard
vrai que tu trimbales un bla  ck livre
au nom duquel vous placez ceux qui
vous croisent et ne paient pas leurs dettes de jeu
non j'ai un un cahier noir dans lequel
j'écris des
choses que
je mets en chansons le célèbre comédien
David Lee Roth a dit
que les critiques de rock n'aiment qu'Elvis  Costello
parce qu'il est d'une beauté dévastatrice
juste comme ça
pouvez-vous commenter cela
non je pense qu'il dit seulement que parce qu'il
ressemble à une imitatrice n'est-ce
pas un problème que vous ayez toujours eu une
meilleure presse que les ventes ici
je ne sais pas parce que  Je ne sais pas lire le français
donc je ne sais pas ce qu'ils disent et
vous dites qu'après tant de combinaisons
d'un accord deux accords trois accords qu'on
ne peut écrire qu'une ou deux bonnes chansons
et vous persistez toujours à sortir un
nouvel album  ah je ce n'est pas la
citation complète j'ai dit des chansons de rock and roll
il y a plus d'une façon d'écorcher un chat
tu as dit qu'à 17 ans tu ressemblais et te sentais
30. comment te sens-tu maintenant
l'âge des Miracles est dans le passé
[Musique]